meanwhile the Lefty's latest Equity
insanity is coming after the classroom
and parents are fuming get this the
California school district is mixing
honors classes for a one-size-fits-all
approach so sorry if your kid is gifted
really good in school and working really
hard the district says their plan will
level the playing field but parents
aren't buying that
we want to provide equal opportunity to
all students and a lot of people would
also agree that we want to provide uh
the students are based on their
individual need but the the way that
this plan is is a draft that Equity is
is a Divine in terms of achieving equal
outcomes and that seemingly at all costs
by getting rid of honors
it's sickening South Carolina Senator
Tim Scott says it's time to punch back
at the left's attempt to take over
education
that was bureaucrats and Big labor
bosses block our kids
from their Highest Potential
it leaves Paris rights and family
choices and funding students instead of
systems you know in some districts have
backed off this guys because they
realize that they their parents spoke up
and said this is not tolerable but this
district is going through with it Dana
what is the big deal have an honor
student have a guy who have their class
their curriculum dumbed down is that
okay it's absolutely not okay and if you
go back to the Glenn Younkin campaign
that surprise Democrats I think that
they didn't realize how potent this
issue of education is for parents Across
America he was able to win over
independent voters because he said at
every campaign stop I will make sure
that there is advanced math offered in
every High School across this state and
he would get a standing ovation for that
line so having somebody that is
in your class or in your in your like in
the larger classroom that is achieving
something one you can be proud of them
and also it makes you try to be better I
think the comp we are still competitive
people in inherently we don't want to be
dumbed down we have there's a desire to
achieve and if there are people who
don't want to achieve that's fine you
don't have to but to take it away from
people in the name of equity is gross
the problem is uh Jesse with too many
Asian kids in the Honors that make only
10 of the student body uh but 34 of the
honors classes and they gotta they got
to fix that
are you saying there's too many Asians
that are smart yep
that culture there is doing your
homework you're going to do extra you're
going to get up early in the morning and
you're going to work out late and maybe
not do Sports
right
um I'm not going to go down that road
Brian but
I want to but I'm not going to I never
felt when I wasn't in any advanced
placement classes that I was being left
out I never felt upset about that your
parents complained I distinguished
myself in other ways yeah like on the
football field you look like you don't
believe me I don't the stage manager
just laughed
in communist countries they still have
advanced placement in China in Russia
they allow for a gifted or bright
students to take different levels of of
course work so they can become rocket
scientists we don't do this with artists
we don't do this with athletes why would
we do that to our school what if Steve
Jobs had to sit in the science class
with a bunch of dummies so the dummies
felt better we wouldn't have a computer
and we'd still be on typewriters right
and our fingers would be fine you would
have nothing to steal so it would be
unbelievable a lot of broad stereotypes
yeah you do like that so I'll be a media
instead of you so judge this to me gets
the foundation what makes America great
we compete we don't win all the time we
want to compete with each other and then
you put steel together and it makes
something special what they're doing is
they're taking away the opportunity from
students who are capable of advanced
study and if you look at it that way you
realize that they're looking for this
Equity this equality of opportunity and
outcome I don't know what that means you
know like my grandson okay he could do
ABC through Z and he's 18 months old
okay my son didn't talk until he was
three I mean you take advantage of one
and you say this kid is linguistic and
let's let's use that as a trend or an
opportunity to teach him more okay I
mean it just is a question of some
people slow down the pace some people if
they're too smart you you bore them and
they end up not competing and
challenging themselves and for kids who
are too slow if the course is too fast
for them then they become truants and
they dry drop out it's just not a good
thing they tried it in New York and they
tried it in San Diego and it didn't work
and they probably want to try it in
Culver City in California here's I'm
sure you know that we simplify the
rundown because we knew who we were
dealing with because we want to have
equal outcomes I'm only kidding this one
kid uh this one uh Dishonored student's
parents said my kid is now and with
everybody else and she's getting an A
plus plus in English she doesn't want
that she wants a heart of class it's
complete nonsense and like all the
attempts that the work Brigade make to
make things supposedly fairer and more
equal what it actually creates is a new
unfairness so the bright kids get
punished I remember the rot started
actually in England I'll take the rap
for this of this mentality when egg and
Spoon races were banned at a school in
Scarborough in the north of England
and they changed it to egg balancing
because they got too competitive kids
were trying to be too good at running
with their Reagan spoon
so it became egg balancing event in
which they raced against a clock not
against each other and the kids could
opt out altogether if they wanted even
if their parents wanted them to compete
they were allowed to say to their
parents no
this is what happened in my country
right and this is the way I see what you
lose when you lose the Competitive Edge
when you think competition is the enemy
when you start to Value mediocrity over
achievement and success you end up in
this ridiculous position and they call
themselves Equity Warriors it is a war
actually and if America was to get back
to being absolutely number one in all
the metrics educationally where China
dominates and Asia dominates then it's
got to start celebrating success we know
we've got to a place now I was laughing
about it last night with someone
you see on Instagram people and they say
I'm so proud of myself I just passed my
driving test at the seventh attempt I'm
so proud I'm like why would you even
post that I don't know what are you
proud of you're one of the worst drivers
in history and you're now telling us
you've failed six times suck it up
quietly and get in your car and try not
to kill people but that's the mentality
we celebrate that that would have got
liked a million times good on you proud
that's the problem right egg and Spoon
races and celebrating your seventh
attempt at passing and driving you go
out every night am I right I liked it
it's unbelievable 23 schools in Illinois
23 schools in Baltimore uh they have
zero kids proficient in math and
readings all right I know it's just you
know so we did a short story about our
Newsroom about that today in the Chicago
Public Schools gave us a statement that
said well we are right in line with all
the other big city schools like that's
really actually not something to brag
about guys they're musical chairs
they'll be pull one chair away one kid
would be crying they'd hit the ground no
chair you lost let's do it we were a
tougher generation
they really tied us to the chair
all right I went on Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now